this Friday December 2nd 6 p.m Eastern
Standard time but all me bro who are we
going live with we're going live with
sunny Faz and his mom and his mom yes
and his mom they're about to confront us
about the biggest Muslim stereotypes
Islamic stereotypes things they've been
taught they're going to ask us about
clarification they're going to ask us
about why we believe about what we
believe we're going to ask them about
why they believe about what they believe
put that on your calendar this Friday
December 2nd at 6 PM EST 11 p.m UK time
it's a live stream not pre-recorded you
can ask your questions do your thing
inshallah make sure you guys come and
tune in your overview of what you said
about my overview was very simple my
overview was if rainbow flags were the
fashion of English people and we wore
them all the time I'm sure Qatar would
let us in with the t-shirts if nobody
ever wears them in history and you show
up at the arena with one you are
intentionally trying to provoke a
culture
into telling you to go home and change
your t-shirts you can paint them as a
bad guy and I believe that they should
skulls that was the gist of what I said
imagine being a generic football fan
just a guy who likes football yeah it's
pretty name coming imagine being a
generic football fan just a guy who
likes football you don't give a [ __ ]
about any of these political statements
any of this garbage and now all of a
sudden you're by just watching the
football games and some more supporting
football you're on the side of mass
I don't know who you are what are they
doing Mass degeneracy like it's Insanity
you can't just like football now or
can't you just you know have sex with
who you want in your house without
having to show everyone in the world cup
bro if you're lucky I want Mr Producer
because I saw some English TV show there
was an English TV show thanks there's an
English TV show just yeah let's leave it
bro thanks thanks
the there's an English TV show and it's
one of these guys he's one of them
football pundits I don't know and it's
BBC Two or something there's a full
three minute singing and dancing just
saying how important it is to have
rainbow armbands why I don't get it why
can't people just play football why do
they have to mix in this agenda with
everything yeah it's like the West has
no culture besides that it's like oh bro
listen I gotta I gotta pause that list
to like have the video left but listen
shout out to one of my boys I saw a tick
tock from him I think just yesterday or
today earlier and he was saying we're
not saying we can't you know you can't
do what you want to do behind closed
doors whatever you want in your hotel
room you're here in Qatar for the World
Cup whatever
why do you got to come into the public
sphere in public and try to directly go
against and disrespect our culture as
Muslims
our tradition as Muslims our values as
followers of Islam why do you think
we're going to stand by that so there's
a difference it's not it's not a matter
of we can't say you know we're not
saying what you can or can't do behind
closed doors and all that we advise you
not to right we we stand against it what
are we going to do if it's behind closed
doors Bro think about it but yeah yeah
out in public World running around with
these things you know and before we
resume it bro please go in yeah I was
just gonna say like I want to give a
personal example because that for some
reason when you phrase it like that the
way you didn't the way energy did people
just don't want to understand it and
it's really stupid so let's put it in a
very easy to understand way imagine you
invited a friend over to your house to
watch the World Cup or whatever and you
told them listen I have a very strict
religious practice we don't eat pork so
do not bring pork to my house I know
you're bringing food do not let it be
pork you know they understand what you
said right you know that they know 100
you do not eat pork they should not
bring pork and then they bring pork to
your house and they say listen bro it's
a free country you told me are you gonna
ever let that that person back in your
house are you going to consider them a
friend are you going to consider them
someone who's respectful of you and your
beliefs and practices no you would not
so how come when these white people
frankly they're all just white people
come to our lands and our countries this
time not to steal oil and kill people to
wear something they know very clearly we
do not allow to be exacerbated publicly
they only have one intention and that's
the disrespect the problem with these
kuffar with these with these with these
enemies of Islam bro is they realize
that in a weird you know time where
everyone's trying to paint Islam a
certain way we're hosting the World Cup
bro
we're hosting I would even argue the
best World Cup thus far with so much
hype and they can't have that bro
they're trying to slander in like any
way possible
yeah you know 100 yeah let's continue
we'll get back the last piece of culture
the pride flag and I don't give a [ __ ]
if people are gay I don't care you'll be
as gay as you want but why do you have
to not why don't you go to another
country and make sure that they
understand how important it is that you
believe that that's an important thing
well interestingly enough Andrew in the
argument of Love Is Love and we should
celebrate and make legal all types of
love if you are from Qatar and you are a
Muslim and you live in England you
cannot legally marry three or four women
polygamy is against the law in England
so if we were to hold the World Cup in
England could the Qatari players have
their Pro polygamy Pro multi-wive uh
armbands on but I don't think they would
I don't know because no because they
don't they don't want to push their
culture on other people they're just
happy being who they are and I think
that that's what every culture should do
yeah because it's absolutely not only
narrative to believe that your
worldviews are somehow shared by Every
Other Nation on Earth it's actually
amazing that the West pretends to be
moral and has any kind of moral High
Ground if you look at the track records
of the West whether it's starting Wars
or
look at some of the ideas The Matrix is
performing I didn't say this yesterday
yeah there's Matrix I mean the idea is
that the Matrix reporting now just a
real quick friendly message from uh your
host right here
to the Haram police we do not condone
smoking cigars or smoking of any kind
whatsoever
and we're not endorsing it
by not blurring this out thank you very
much what's the populations of the West
are absolutely not really degenerate
they're not moral you're going to sit
there and say that you know it's okay to
chop people's dicks off at the age of
eight and nine and that's somehow good
and then you'll talk to others about
morality if there's absolutely nothing
moral about the West the West is
disgusting in many various forms to sit
there and tell pretend that they know so
much more than other countries is
absolutely not only disrespectful so by
most metrics Qatar is a country
outperforms nearly every Western Country
yeah it's safer they have families let
lower divorce rate they're doing
something right so for us to sit come
along and say no they're doing
everything wrong they have to believe
the way we think is absolutely not the
arrogant
see you can't win with these go far as
well because when you say they have
lower divorcer they're like oh they're
women just shut up and they're like okay
but then you you find a woman that's
like happily like promoting you know
family values and Islam and all this oh
she's internalized misogyny she's
brainwashed there's no way to win with
them bro
yeah they'll just they'll just they'll
put it back on another stereotype always
they'll put it back in the stereotype
um and again like you said there's no
winning with these people um but what
does one is logic and facts and
rationality and you know sound arguments
islamically
we don't differentiate between a gay
person and a straight person believe it
or not
we don't you know you know who does
differentiate between gay uh and
straight people what they're the ones
who are like you're gay you're straight
be proud by the way that you're gay
you're straight okay anyways you're this
you're that you're trans you're you're
cue your eye you're Z you're using their
bro they're about to freaking bring more
letters of the alphabet because they're
running out at this point
and they make it they make it the the
entire point of their personality they
make it the point of the personality
they make it who they are what they are
and and they you cannot distinguish you
know up one person from another except
if they're great they're straight or
whatever you know or if they're a
blocker they're white or whatever so
these very arbitrary things are exactly
what the West is pushing in Qatar
if you are gay you will not you know
socially be labeled with this thing of
oh this person is homosexual this person
is heterosexual they don't talk about it
they don't care because they are not
publicly indecent enough to display it
publicly no that what like you were
mentioning what goes on behind closed
doors whatever the Sharia doesn't
operate there you're not going to have
CCTV in your room or police officers you
know looking into your room it's even
Haram to spy on people imagine that
imagine for a punish for a crime like
that like adultery or homosexuality be
punished you need Witnesses you need at
least four male Witnesses who are Pious
and so on and so forth that can argue
the same exact story and at the same
time it's Haram to spy on people so how
are they even gonna see it it's like
that's crazy man
and and we're going to be smart as
Muslims too to see how they manipulate
the masses or how they brainwash because
they're gonna say things and take things
out of context like oh if two gay guys
do X in public then Sharia law says this
bro if a man and a woman does X in
public Sharia law can still do that
because it's not about guy and girl or
guy and guy in every single punishment
but sometimes the crime is doing
something in public
but then they'll take you I know and and
this is not a thing we're not gonna
enjoy good and forbid evil and we're not
against LGBT and all this but my point
is do you see the way that they take
things out of context and they just
paint those as you know
yeah 100 and it's funny because like
they're so clearly hypocritical
BBC all these these news organizations
are so clearly hypocritical even even
Piers Morgan is calling them out on
their hypocrisy that the UK uh and and
Canada and America and these Western
countries
they are doing the most atrocious things
even like Ukraine supporting Israel
against the Palestinian people like
these things are so clearly hypocritical
to everything that they've been
preaching and stand for and as soon as
you know white uh white people or or
Christian uh Christian uh majority
countries or Western propaganda is
attacked or pushed against in any way
they go to the human rights they go to
the you know the the love who you love
and the believe what you want to believe
and all that stuff fighting for these
things so much but they will not allow
it for anybody else
it's it's so it's it's crazy how clear
they are you know in their hypocrisy but
refuse to back down from it and just I
wanted I wanted to be clear for the
people